polonium was another element discovered
by Madame Curie Madame Curie was polish
though she did most of her research if
not all of it in Paris but and so
polonium is named after Poland and
polonium is an element which has been
not very important until the invention
of atomic bombs and then polonium became
an absolutely crucial material because
it is used or was used as a trigger in
the center of the original atomic bombs
one of the difficulty is that it has a
very short half-life if you have a lump
of polonium half of it decays away in
138 days so if you keep it too long it's
gone or most of it's gone and therefore
in the early days of producing atomic
bombs that is with her Oshima and
Nagasaki and so on the limiting factor
in producing the bombs was actually a
production of polonium for the trigger
rather than the enriched uranium or the
plutonium that was being used for the
bombs themselves quite recently polonium
has had a new lease of notoriety because
it was used in this tragic poisoning
case where a large dose of polonium was
given to unfortunate Russian citizen
visiting the UK and it's still unclear
where the polonium came from but it is a
very unusual material and difficult for
ordinary individuals to find if it's
ingested because it's decaying so fast
the radioactivity can cause all sorts of
very unpleasant effects and again it's
probably poisonous as well